awesome Big Ups to hint and everybody
for you know putting this together it's
always very exciting so just a quick
around the room how many people here are
JavaScript users or programmers awesome
how many people here are aware or even
use javascript in a functional
programming type of way yeah of those
people how many people know the
difference between imperative JavaScript
functionally and declarative JavaScript
all right good we got to a point so
that's great
so I'm going to be talking about another
kind of branch of this tonight called
algebraic JavaScript and it's there's a
lot of parallels between programming and
that algebra that we learned in seventh
or eighth or whenever you learned
algebra there's a lot of parallels
between that and there's been a lot of
work mathematically to kind of put
together a relationship between
mathematics and programming it's been
going on for a long time so a little bit
about me
my name is Ian Hoffman Hicks you can see
me everywhere on the internet as evil
soft of github z-- all the things I work
for a company called articulate we make
elearning software it's a hundred
percent remote company about 174 of us
do this all over the world and I get the
chance to have a hundred percent
autonomy with my team on how we solve
the problems that our business needs so
about four years ago we decided you know
I'm getting really tired of these event
loops and getting caught in the stack
flow overflows and all this crap that
comes along with backbone apps and
things like that that we were doing so
we decided to kind of explore what
functional JavaScript could get us and
we started that about four years ago and
it kind of rippled out through all of
the project teams and pretty much the
whole company if they use JavaScript is
doing it functionally so a little bit
about me obviously I use functional
JavaScript I'm a vim user two spaces
over
and no semicolons so if that makes you
cringe I'm sorry you can also see me in
all these places so I'm on github
Twitter the youtubes
and I have a couple lessons on egghead
all is evil soft in all those locations
so before we get started we're gonna do
a little housekeeping and if you haven't
seen this movie house party with kitten
play from the early 90s I really
recommend seeing it it's one of the best
hip hop movies that words ever created
so we'll get into this we'll talk about
sets of things so this may not I don't
know how much finite mathematics you've
all have done but we'll kind of just go
over it briefly and show some
connections so in our universe we have
things and as humans we like to give
things labels it just makes it easier to
talk about it point at it and describe
stuff by giving it a label so here I'm
not very creative we're just going to
use lowercase alphas it's going to be
super easy but also we like to look for
certain properties inside of things it
also helps us describe and talk about
those so here how's that coming through
good I was worried about the color
choice ah no but we're not doing a
projector so it works out great so we'd
like to give certain things attributes
and once they have these attributes we
also as humans like to kind of
categorize them and put them together so
certain things that have certain
attributes we can go ahead and just put
them together and talk about them as a
whole and the relationships that they
have to each other that's a horrible way
of saying that now the properties that
they share so and also we like to give
these categories names again not very
creative so we're just going to go a B
and C for these one of the things you
might notice though and this is kind of
convention in set theory a lot of the
sets have capital names
are you that or some sort of symbol
script symbol and usually the elements
or lowercase just a matter of convention
so again one of the things we can do
with these is or some of the properties
of sets are I can pick any one of these
L
at any point and I did there's no
structure to him so I don't need to
iterate over like going through the
alphabet a deg to finally get to K I can
just pick K right out there's no
structure or anything to these and if I
were to pick K again K will always be
equal to K but if I compare K to
something else it's not K and if
anything else that I pick out of there
is equal to K that thing has to be K
very important so again what the heck
does this have to do about JavaScript so
we'll kind of clear the board here and
we'll give them some more familiar type
of things we'll pick any JavaScript
value just a value that can be used in
JavaScript and it's a it's not a
strictly typed language so you can use
these at any point in time in your code
no need to say this is this this is that
but you'll notice a lot of these have
similarities and things in common some
of them are strings numbers a boolean
and even null null is really its own
type that has one element in it another
thing like that is undefined undefined
is also a type that only has one element
in it a lot of people think it's nothing
but it's not nothing it's something you
can't have nothing in programming no
matter what they say so to look at some
of these similarities between sets and
what we know of is types if I were to
pick out an a say it's number I can take
42 and assign it to a value I didn't
have to count from zero to get up to 42
I just instantiate it by giving it a
value and if I were to pick 42 again
sorry let me back up also if I were to
pick a it's reflexive so a will always
be equal to a we take that for granted
but it's a really neat thing that a is
always equal to a it gives us a lot of
how would you say guarantees in life if
a was never equal to a a lot of things
would break down also if we were to pick
it again and assign it to another
variable even though it's another
instance of that it is always by value
going to be equal to a again and it's
symmetric so a is equal to b and b is
equal to a so there's that symmetry
there on top of it
it's another thing that you would see in
in normal sets and if I were to pick
anything else that is not going to be
equal to a and if a is equal to B C is
also not going to be equal to a these
are all things we take for granted but
it's these types sorts of things that
show the similarities between set theory
and actual programming that we do day to
day so a lot of this that we're going to
discuss those little bit diagrams dot
diagrams don't tell much so we're going
to use a convention of diagramming
that's used in a branch of mathematics
called category theory so in here we're
going to represent any type as a
lowercase letter so this a could be any
type I'm saying for any type string
number whatever anytime you see a
lowercase it usually means any type and
then also B B could be equal to a it
could be the same type but it doesn't
have to be it gets a little confusing
but don't worry about it we'll get there
so we like to represent relationships
between types with these arrows and for
us in JavaScript these arrows represent
functions so to kind of see what that
looks like say we were to have an arrow
F that goes from string to number so
it's just a function right I give it a
string and it's going to give me back a
number also that notation there is a fun
little notation to learn more on that
later so we'll just pick that arbitrary
F and we'll give it a name and of course
there's a great function called length
that would take a string and then return
the length of it as you see I put in a
string that is nice and it returns me
back a four so in this way there's
directionality I've moved from a value
inside of string into a value of number
and this happens for anything that's
typed like that or any to any sort of
function so now that we know diagrams we
can talk about the most important
founder or the foundation of functional
programming and that's function
composition the only thing that's even
more important to that is a thing called
identity but we won't get into that
basically it's just something you give
it it and it gives you that thing back
but we have to
have that and we have to have
composition in order for all of this to
work
so what composition is is if I were to
take any type b2 any type or any type a
to any type b and i have a function f
any tie any function of that type that
moves between there and I have a
function from B to C I should always be
able to create what's called a
composition and that we typically note
that as G composed with F or this could
be read G after F it's just a way to
keep track of that now that's all very
abstract so let's know actually we're
not at that part I added this part this
morning huh so the only way we could
really do that and is if we were to take
some value X that's an A and then pass
it to F and then that goes to G giving
us the result and we run into this a lot
if you go look through your code you'll
see this throughout your code if you're
not already doing functional composition
so we can even create a new function
that's G after F that just takes a value
of X and now we have a function that is
the composition of F and G but we can
even make it more generic by making a
really simple function that takes a
function G takes a function f then takes
that value X and then applies the
composition so now I can pass in any
function G and any function X and as
long or F and as long as their types
match up I have a valid composition and
again we'll run into this a lot that's
the foundation of functional programming
so let's move that into JavaScript and
see kind of like how this plays down or
plays out so we'll start with an object
a string and a number is our type we'll
create a function called user that goes
from object to string now on this all
we're going to do is take an object pull
the user off of it and then return that
user does everyone use arrow functions a
lot does this to read this cool so we're
going to that will get us and we're
assuming here that user is always going
to be a string
remember it's JavaScript but we're going
to say that we're good programmers and
always make sure that we pass an object
to this and it will always be a string
also I can then take a length that same
function and or I can take a length
function that does the same exact thing
I'd give it a string well string has
length property on it I can just pull
that off and return it so now I have a
function that goes from string to number
and I can go by these into one super
mega function called user length which
now goes from object to number and using
that little function the compose that we
made earlier I can just pass in length
pass in user and I have a function that
when I pass in a user of Edna it gives
me back four so that's functional
composition in a nutshell there's one
more aspect to it that I didn't really
mention and it's really funny you'll
hear a lot of people say your functions
have to be pure your functions have to
be pure and then they give you this big
old tutorial on why your functions have
to be pure and referential transparency
the only reason your functions have to
be pure is because your diagrams have to
commute and all the diagrams we'll be
showing here are what are called
communitive diagrams so what I mean by
commute is if I were to take the path
from F to G and I were to take the path
from G to F whatever I start at in a I
always always must return the same C so
to see what that looks like we'll go
back to our example if I were to take
the user Billy and send it on this path
from user to length I have to map that
to five it will always map to five and
then with this composition that always
has to map to five no matter what and
that has to happen for every object that
goes to any of these functions and
that's why your functions have to be
pure because if your functions aren't
pure then they're not going to commute
and I if I run user lengths at a
different time than user and there's a
side-effect in there this diagram won't
commute and all of it breaks down so
this is why it's very important to
always have pure fun
and we can see here to test this if we
just take the X pass it to user and then
pass the result of that to length it
must always equal the user length but we
know that's the case because that's how
you make composition so as long as your
functions are pure you're always going
to commute so that's it for the wrap-up
or for the how would you say the
housekeeping so now let's get to the
algebra and don't worry I just really
wanted to put that stuff in your head so
it'll make it easier for the rest of
this then you can say like oh that's
composition oh that's that all right so
on to the algebra so what the heck does
JavaScript have to do with algebra well
we can look at a comparison for each
operation in arithmetic algebra and
JavaScript in the way that we're
thinking about it so there are three
main operations with their inverses
javascript we cannot do the inverse
operations because we're not a compliant
ring and if you didn't take abstract
algebra you probably have no idea where
the ring is
but that's okay we're not going to talk
about them just something to keep in the
back of your mind we're not a ring so if
you look at addition the operation on
that in arithmetic that would just be a
simple 220 plus 2 so that gets you 22 in
algebra we do an A plus B and each one
of those could be terms it's basically
the addition of terms but in JavaScript
we have the same the only difference is
these aren't variables these are types
so we're basically adding two types
together whenever we do this and if you
remember set theory kind of think of it
as a union of sets but it's a special
union union of sets and the reason why
it's special is because it's actually
based off multiplication that's why it's
a little bit different than just a
simple union so in multiplication we use
the cross operator or the x2 between our
values to multiply them together in
algebra we have the dot or sometimes we
just put them together for scaling and
things like that but in algebra we
actually multiply two types together
so try to think what the heck could that
mean multiply two types together now
we're only going to cover these two
there's also exponential operations so
in arithmetic that would be you know
five to the second or five squared in
algebra we'd have a 2b and in JavaScript
we also have a two B but the difference
here is and that's backwards it should
actually be B to a sorry about that
it's a function so it's basically what's
called a function type so it's a type
that wraps the function we don't need to
get into that for our examples today but
just know that there is exponentiation
all right so we're gonna start with
product types because some types or the
the pluses the addition portion of it it
pretty much comes from a product type so
going to our diagrams we represent a
cross B as the type and then we have
these two projection functions that's
why it says PI P for projection and
you'll notice in a lot of category
theory and abstract algebra they like
Greek for some reason don't know why
what they do so you'll see it all over
the place but a type or a product type
it has the property of having two
projection functions and what that does
is on the left side of it it can take
that type the the product and pull out
the left side and it can also take the
right side or the B of the product and
if you pass it to pi/2 that's going to
take out the B side of it so I can
remove it from its context now you
probably have used these a lot if you
think about like screen positioning you
have an X and a y-coordinate that's what
this is it's basically just a pair right
so we would have whatever our y
coordinate is whatever our x coordinate
is and then from there we can move them
individually they're independent of each
other so I can move the width and that
doesn't affect the height or I can move
it on the X and
doesn't affect the why I could implement
rules to say hey when it gets to the end
of this go ahead and increment the y but
I don't have to do that they live fully
independent of each other
and that's the actual property that
we're gonna exploit tonight is that
independence so to see what this looks
like in JavaScript we'll go ahead and
use a pair so if I were to have a pair
of number and Bowl I couldn't stand it
like this now we're going to be using a
library called crocks which is a library
that implements algebraic data types and
has all of this stuff available so in
that library there is a type called pair
so I can instantiate a pair of P and on
the left side I'll go ahead and put 42
on it and on the right side I'll just
put true so now this matches our ciggy
of num of number bold so our projection
functions are actually FST which stands
for first and snd which stands for
second so for first if I were to run
first on that P I would pull out 42 if I
were to run second on that of course get
true if that was false or whatever I
would just pull it out so these
functions come equipped with pair real
simple but it's it's mostly the
independence that we care about the fact
that these two things exist side by side
and as a matter of fact you can think of
a product as having this and that to tie
it in to boolean logic which is another
branch of finite mathematics but this
also translates into boolean logic as
well all of this stuff is related but
you can think of it having a num and a
bull they exist at the same time no
matter what so from that we can create
some types now in category theory we
have these things called Co so if we
were to put a if we were to preference
coke preference preface thank you if we
were to preface code to anything it
gives it the opposite and what that
means is we flip the arrows so for
instance if you eat cocoa puffs you're
really just eating puffs
okay so uh anyway sorry again we like
our Greek so and if you look here we
took those projections and the only
thing we did is inverted them so now
instead of pointing out and projecting
out they actually inject in and that's
why we use iota for the actual injection
functions again with the Greek I don't
know why and we're going to have one on
the Left which is L 1 and then 1 on the
iota 1 and then 1 on the right which is
iota 2 so what this looks like in
JavaScript using the Crocs library is we
have a type called either which is the
canonical type for a probably some type
in anywhere but basically it has a
number on the left and a boolean on the
right but the difference here is we have
to construct into it so remember with
the projection or with the product types
we're extracting so we're projecting out
with these we have to inject in so we do
that with a number of constructors one
if we want it to be on the left side we
would use left and we would pass that a
number and then one for the right side
which would give us the right side which
in this case would we want it to be a
bull and again if I pass this in I now
get an instance of either which is a
left instance that has 42 on it and also
on the right side I have a right if I
were to construct it using right I would
get back an instance that wraps that
boolean but it's been tagged with right
and that's the major difference here
between a set Union and what we're
working with here is this is called the
tagged Union so even if it was number
and number I would know is that a left
number or a right number and I could
respond accordingly based on any
information we want to give it or any
reason for it being left or it being
right so that's that's the main
difference there so while we could think
of product as this and that we could
think of some types as
or that there will only ever be one
instance here we can't have a left and a
right we can only have a left or a right
which is pretty neat but you'll notice
it's just by shifting those arrows we
get a whole new type that behaves in a
whole different way that we can we can
utilize and you run into that a lot in a
category theory and abstract algebra so
we're done with the theory that's it I
promise there'll be no more diagrams
there's not going to be any more talk of
algebra we're going to get to the code
so if you want you could take a wee
stretch get it out of your head and
forget all this stuff doesn't matter so
we'll move on all right now let's take
all of this theory and let's do some
code so these are our requirements I
always thought a good project man but I
always think Chad is a great project
manager right like don't you just want
to take work from someone named Chad but
I was like it's weird so I just took the
quote out but Chad says that given an
unsanitized list of learner records we
want to provide a list of string learner
names with a length greater than 3 that
passes with the score of 70% or higher
can you tell I work for an e-learning
company so just by looking at these now
me personally when I was doing this
internal or imperative development and
stuff and object-oriented stuff most of
my life up until about four years ago I
would really just see this as two things
all right we need to filter invalid
records and we need to transform each
record into a learner name like that's
what I gleaned from this I'm like these
are my requirements so taking those as
our requirements and working on our data
we see what he means now by unsanitized
so this is JavaScript and our data could
come from anywhere so we were hoping
that we would have a list of record
types but we got all these nulls in
there and we got like 22 what the heck
is that learner is not even a string
it's a null like no one knows where this
is coming from so we're gonna have to as
we build these applications account for
that because we don't like to sanitize
our data it's probably too expensive
anyway it's coming from many sources
right so this is what our main logic
will look like we're just going to have
a simple function that checks to see is
it valid and we just take in a wreck and
because the data is not sanitized
there's a lot of silly little JavaScript
things that we have to do so we'll
basically just check to see hey is it a
record is it is it a positive value this
way we're not processing any things with
nulls or undefined that are going to
throw errors once we start grabbing on
their properties and then we have a
couple helpers like is string and
basically this is just a function to
check to see if a value is string and
then on top of that we're going to check
to see all right it's a string so what's
the length of that string if it's
greater than 3 we're good to go and we
can move on now we're also going to
check in this same function is this a
number for our score like we can't
really do a relational comparison yeah
it's still valid we can't do a
relational comparison on this if it's
not a number because we're comparing it
to a number and we don't want to get
into some weird coercion magic and
things like that
so we want to check that firsthand
before we have some hard to find bugs so
that's basically what we're going to do
to see if it's invalid the other thing
we need to do is transform this record
based on our stuff so we have these
simple functions basically that's going
to also check to see if rec is a string
even though we already did that then
it's going or is valid then we're going
to check to see if Lerner's a string if
it is we're going to return the learner
otherwise we're going to return unknown
but the way we're gonna lay this out
will probably ever never never hit that
unknown value so with those two
requirements you might be thinking hey I
read getify book and he knows everything
about functional programming so we're
gonna do this functional program and
this is an example of what I call
imperative functional programming notice
we're creating variables we're doing
things we're manually putting together
this calling this after that anyway so
what we would do is filter this on is
valid and then after that we just map in
our transition boom we're done right but
this is a little disgusting does anyone
know why I'm using such vulgar language
and calling this disgusting is it
evident so we have multiple iterations
over this structure yeah we saw that we
were only going over six things but what
happens if we get 10,000 things and what
if all 10,000 of those things are valid
so while we're looping over it to filter
amount we're now also going to have to
loop over it to map them and do our
transformation so even though it did
match our requirements there's a little
gotcha there that you'll run into as
soon as you get successful and have a
lot more than just five learner records
so we could take the old school's route
and we'll just use imperative for loops
so the issue with this in my opinion one
of the issues is we have to create this
accumulator and that accumulator is
outside of our iteration so if we wanted
to change this and use it somewhere else
or something like that all of that
information has to transport to that new
thing so we have to create an
accumulator that accumulator has to be
the same name that's used inside of our
functions so there's really no easy way
to extend this using an imperative thing
and you end up with a bunch of these
little functions depending on your model
all over your code where you're doing
one thing but just changing something
slightly but you have to copypasta that
stuff all over which is a great emoji
just do policemen spaghetti and that
means copy pasta right so let's go to
functionally imperative now I see this
all the time and this is bad I don't
know why people do this so they're
thinking you know what I'm not using a
for loop anymore I'm just going to use
for each but you notice the same problem
with that for loop is here the only
difference is we didn't have to create a
variable called rec we were
here see we had to actually constat
wreck the only difference between this
code and that code is the fact that we
don't have to create that variable we'll
get it in is the function but this has
the same problems so much boilerplate
and this is one of the problems I have
with imperative programming is and you
don't really think about it but if we
look at these we have is valid and get
learner that's our business logic like
as that is the logic that was given to
us by our the project manager whatever
business analyst whatever we use so
every single one of these examples do
the same thing the only difference is
how do we put together the calls to
implement our two business requirements
that we have and all of this is
boilerplate we would have to move this
over to something else we always have to
put this in anytime we're writing any
type of imperative code think of all the
if statements that you've written that
are exactly the same but one variable
name has changed it's all boilerplate
and how many people have said oh my gosh
I love this library I have to get to
write all this boilerplate to get it set
up nobody right but yeah we do this day
in and day out with our imperative code
all we do is just write boilerplate and
we don't even really stop to think about
it the only difference is it's just how
do we put these two business
requirements together that's that's the
only thing that we really need to solve
as developers so well we're gonna try to
do is put together or see if we can take
those little tidbits of algebra that we
learned a little bit ago that I told you
to forget all about and see if we can
create this see if we can use this to
solve those problems that I have now one
of the major problems is our
requirements we took them very
holistically so if you think about them
there was only two things filter
transform but there's actually a lot
more if you were to break the statement
so first of all we one of the things you
may have noticed is in that validate
function we're validating score and we
were validating whether or not that
username was right so that one function
had to be aware of two different
properties that could or could not be on
there beyond that object and then on top
of that how do we or it would have to
know how that should behave or what we
consider valid for each of those so
we've really put two concerns or as I
like to say an emoji corn CERN's
together and that's emoji corn - CERN so
and I can't really fault anyone for
thinking that because that's how we
solve these problems right as imperative
or programmers we look at the problem as
a whole and then we start pressing it
out like how many times have you you
know designed a game and you built your
whole like game structure first instead
of working on how do I put one pixel on
the screen now you spend hours building
this stupid game engine and then you
never ever get to put in the pixel on
the stream because you view it
holistically so whenever we kind of do
functional programming we kind of invert
that so we never think of anything
holistically we think about it at the
smallest level and build up from there
so it's just a different way of thinking
from object-oriented or structured code
so using the okay I say all that and
then I do this so using that in a frame
of mind or in that frame of mind we can
break this out to other requirements
like validate the score extract a
learner validate that learner and then
filter valid records and really that's
it so that'll that'll take care of it
instead of two things we're going to
look at this at four things and we're
going to break it down to the smallest
level so with that we're going to do a
little is that can you all read that the
colors all right font size okay all
right so what we're gonna do is just
build this out but we're going to tackle
it one little bit at a time so over on
our right we have that day
that you saw earlier and then on the
left here these are all the functions
that we're going to bring in to kind of
help us put this together no need to
really worry about those yet I'll
explain each of them as we go to
implement them so since we're starting
with score right yeah
so let's validate the score first now
remember I like to think or when you
think of these things you want to go at
the the smallest unit possible so
instead of thinking about a score that's
on an object we're gonna just think
about a number we don't care if it's on
an object we don't care about things
like that we'll implement how do we
validate this just as a number and then
we'll start building up from there so
here for valid score this is really
pretty simple I guess we need to check
to see oh also I'm sorry let me back up
we also have this greater than or equal
to function so you may not I don't know
if you could see that but it's a curried
function and we're gonna take an A and
then we're gonna take a b and then we're
gonna see if b is greater than or equal
to a so when you see this laid out it'll
actually read really really nice right
now it's probably like whoa those are
kind of flipped and strange but when we
go to actually use this thing it'll read
kind of like English which makes it real
easy to figure out what's going on there
so what we're gonna do here is we want
to take a number and we want to take
that number to be score and we're going
to use a function on this called and
score I think that's right we're gonna
use a function on here called and and
what and does is it takes two predicate
functions every one here no two
predicate function is it's a function
that takes something returns a boolean
it basically tells you yes or no so what
we're going to do this and function
takes two boolean functions and then
it's going to take a value and it's
going to pass that value to each of the
functions and then do an and on them so
we'll have one function that goes in
gets tested twice and if it both passes
is true it'll return true if one of them
fail
it pails so just to see what that looks
like
will do and is number and what's another
good one
we'll use our greater than or equal to
and here we'll say seventy okay
and you'll notice from the signature
there this is going to take in a number
and return a function that takes an A to
a boolean so now we're going to return
this function feel like I'm missing
something here what am I missing
what was that yeah so and that's what
we're doing is we're leaving that third
thing off so that way it's going to be a
function that's ready to take that last
thing so now I can put it in a map I can
put it in anything and it's now a
function that's going to run that over
any value that we pass it so we get a
new function I think I'm missing a thing
here so if we were to come down here and
check to see we'll do valid score and if
we pass in let's see thank you that's
what I was doing wrong didn't look right
okay so if I were to pass in a valid
score of 70 so here we're going to say
70 is the ballots score and then I go
ahead and pass in know what's a good
thing to pass in now one thing we don't
need is that because that's just silly
we'll pass in 60 so we see that returns
false if I were to pass in a string of
60 that also returns false because it's
not a number
if I were to pass in what is going on
I am so ridiculous so if I were to pass
in anything like undefined like say I
want to pass an undefined it's not gonna
fail its just gonna say false because
undefined is not a number and if I were
to pass in 78 it returns true so now we
have a neat function that's going to
validate score but remember earlier when
I was talking about composition and how
you know remember what it looked like
it's kind of hard to see it here but
this function here that's the last one
is actually that would be the F in that
example and this one here would be the G
so and this right here would be the X
right so because we know how composition
works we can actually make this point
free and get rid of the score and
bringing that score in just are you
kidding me right now no I'm not kidding
it is my keyboard but I refuse all right
so I can do the is number and we close
that out and here I can do greater than
or equal to and get rid of that and now
I have a function that is ready to
accept score or a score and then it's
going to populate the first attribute of
that gray or the first parameter of that
greater than equal to and then that
function is going to go into the second
function of that other one and it's
going to give me back the function so
it's the same exact code that we wrote
the only difference is it returns the
function why is that well it's a good
question man hmm well isn't that just a
silly little oh because we need to pass
a thing yeah it is a function so now if
we do 78
or 79 that'll be true but a string 79 of
course will be false so it's the same
exact function the only difference here
is we got rid of having to declare that
score and we put it into that
composition which is the foundation of
all things alright so now that we have
the score taken care of we can take any
number and then check to see if it's a
score we now need to think about well
wait a minute I'm getting this score off
of an object so this needs to come off
of an object somehow and this that and
the other so what we'll do is we'll
create this one and this is a function
that takes a number and then takes a
record that's what we're calling these
and then we'll give you back what's
called a maybe of record so earlier we
talked about either now either is the
canonical sum type but maybe is what's
called a specialized some type so it's
exactly like either in all aspects
except the left side is always fixed to
undefined it's always fixed to a unit
you can never put anything in it
anything you put into it will
automatically map to undefined so that's
the only difference between the two it's
a specialized type so we're saying it
maybe this is good and if it is good
then we'll give it back to you if it's
not good well you get nothing back and
everything is just lost it sounds very
destructive and horrible but it's really
fun and exciting no there's a lot of
uses for it as we'll see here so what
we're going to do is create another
function called passes with and on this
one we are going to take in a score for
score and nope too early right it's too
early for Abraham Lincoln jokes so what
we're going to do here is we'll do
another composition and the first thing
we want to do is actually pull the
compose off of this or not compose we
want to pull score off of this and do we
know we don't what
really want to do is use a function
called prop satisfies and what prop
satisfies does is it takes in a function
and a proper takes in a property name
that could be on an object and it takes
in a function and if that property
satisfies get the name now that
predicate then it will return the whole
object is true right so it's not just
going to pull it off it's just going to
return the whole object back to you
because that prop was satisfied so we're
going to use prop satisfies here and
with prop satisfies like I said that
takes the score or the property name and
we're going to pull it off of score and
then on top of that it's going to take a
dicka dicka ticket or a function and
that function is going to be valid score
and we're going to fix this to score
okay so now we have this passes with
function and let's go ahead and change
this to be digit idatd dot map and we'll
use map here now normally we could just
pass this function in but the version of
node I'm using has since removed the
inspect does anyone know about the
inspect function probably why they
removed it but what it would do is
anytime you put it in your console it
would return whatever that function was
as the display in your console so what I
used to do is on inspect I would give a
string representation of the type and
not the methods on the type but I'm
using this new version of node and I
haven't figured out a way around that
yet so we're gonna do something what I
like to call hockey and we're going to
coerce it into a string because on top
of that I also implement to string to do
the same thing so if I were to use it
inside of a literal or a template little
role or whatever the heck this is called
yeah my JavaScript
where are these things so we're gonna do
passes with and we're going to say 70
here and also we will pass in what I
like to call X and then that should put
it to string so you see this is all true
false true true true so all of these
have passed that initial part of passing
the score if we were to look at the data
and we could just by doing what I like
to call a log data right so if you look
at those records the ones that either
haven't passed themselves like that last
one or the ones that don't have that
they all are false but if you look at
that type I said I was going to return a
maybe of record so there's one little
thing I'm missing here and there's a
function that's called safe and what
safe does is it takes any predicate
function and it's going to run the value
on it and it's going to if it passes
wrap it in what's called adjust which is
the right side of the maybe or if it
doesn't pass is going to return in
nothing which is the left side of the
maybe so now if we look at this now on
for the first ones and the ones that
actually pass we now have a just two and
the record that's there so now we're
inside of our maybe we're feeling good
about ourselves things are going great
and really that's all we need to
validate the score so that's it all of
our score validation is good to go the
only thing that's there are things that
do our score so now the next step is we
need to pull off am i right am i right
we need to extract the learner from this
so we'll do the same sort of thing we're
going to start at the lowest level which
would be the string that we're expecting
and then we're going to work our way up
before I do that though does anyone
notice anything about line 21
yes it can be a composition because the
same thing is happening over here
there's this value that's we're ready to
take a predicate and then over here on
the right we have the validate score and
then over there we have over here we
have the score being put back in so it's
the same exact thing and by the way this
type of argument handling is called data
last so if you think about it everything
or if you were to put the data you want
to work on is the very last argument of
all of your functions every other
argument before that is context on how
to work with your data so this allows
you to actually put these together and
you'll see that there so I want to run
that function validate score but the
context in which I want to run it on is
score so everything before your last
argument is the context and then the
last argument is always your data so and
it makes it easier to change these types
of things and to compile into
compositions so here we'll just do
compose and actually let's do it like
this the last thing we want to do is
safe it's the last thing we want the mid
thing we want to do is prop satisfies
and of course we want to partially apply
that that's what that's called when you
do this it's called partial application
we want to put that to score and the
last thing we want to do is valid score
so now we can get rid of that and we can
get rid of score notice so far the only
variables that we're ever working with
or creating or anything they're all
functions we don't even have arguments
that come into things everything that
we're working with is a function we
haven't declared a single variable yet
except for data which is the data that
we're working on so
just something to note so and if you
look we give it a save and give it a
save and we get the same result because
we're not yeah because we're doing
passes with so now it's just a simple
way of making a composition out of this
alright so now we got the score done
that looks good hunky-dory now we want
to move on to the learner stuff and
again we're going to start at the base
level so the first thing we want to do
is actually pull off the user and the
rest of it should go pretty quick before
I lose Ollie all we will do validate
learner and validate learner of course
takes a record and then returns a
boolean so here we're going to again go
with and and we want to do yes that's
what we want to do so the first thing
we'll do is pull that in with and and
we'll do is numb or is string just so we
can check that and then on top of that
the second thing we want to do is check
the length so we're going to do prop
satisfies length and the function that
we want to actually pass to this is
going to be greater than or equal to
four and that should get us what we want
so if we were to go ahead and map this
over we can make this a a watchman who's
at composition but away yeah but there's
no point I think y'all get that by now
so here we're going to do valid learner
and we don't need any of this it doesn't
need to be partially applied so we see
that we do not have a
valid learner at all and that's because
I got ahead of myself we didn't actually
pull Lerner off of it so it's looking at
all the objects but so for the sake of
time instead of setting that up to do
this we are going to use this function
because you notice we have a validate
learner or yeah valid a learner which as
its first argument takes a function that
goes from record to boolean so since we
just implemented a function call that
goes from record to boolean we'll go
ahead and use that it fits in nicely
it's like I thought about it
so we'll do validate learner validate
learner now I can't blame it on my mouse
pad or my mouse thing I should have just
left that on there validate that's the
last one all right so with this we're
going to take in our function and we're
just going to call this test the the
reason why we're breaking this out and
not putting it in there is if we don't
put a function in there and we say take
this function I can then swap that
function out for anything that I want to
test so maybe I want to check to see if
there's five characters or if it's all
capitalized or whatever it doesn't
matter I can just swap that function out
and then get the reusability of pulling
a user off and running it against some
predicate okay so we're gonna take a
function we're just going to call that
test and then this is where it gets a
little cool I guess so the first thing
we're gonna do is do get prop and what
get prop does it's kind of the same sort
of thing as safe except I give it a prop
name and if that prop exists it will
give it back to me and adjust if that
prop does not exist I'll get a nothing
back again saying that hey something's
wrong there's nothing I can do with this
record so here you go good luck to you
pal so here we're just going to do our
get prop with learner and we'll just
leave it like that
fun now your basic do validate winner
and for here we will pass in that little
function called valid learner and dicka
dicka dirt or here we will pass in X so
now you see that everywhere that there
was an actual learner something that had
learner in there even that one that
isn't null for that one record it still
came back because it was defined we
didn't check to see if it was null or
anything but we were able to actually
pull that off just by using that get
prop function so the next thing we need
to do with this is then do some
validation on it so now that we have it
we can do the same sort of thing let's
make this read a little better and we
can use safe but we're going to get an
error if we do this which is totally
expected and we're just going to test it
with our test function so we get a
nothing why did we give him nothing oh I
know why we got him nothing so it just
went ahead and used that type we didn't
get an error but it's not giving us the
results that we want now the reason for
this is these algebraic bits they can
not only you know map or change
themselves but we can combine the
effects of them so how we do that some
might say we chained the effects of
these so the effect so far that we're
starting to see here with maybe is that
it implements disjunction it implements
you you have this or you don't have this
right so I can take that affect that is
the affect of this type this is where
the term algebraic effects come from I
can take that effect and chained it to a
another function that will then reapply
its own effect to it
so how we do that is by chain now you
also might have heard of this as flatmap
I don't like flatmap it's it talks about
what it's doing but it doesn't talk
about like cuz it Maps it and then
flattens it but it doesn't really talk
about the power of these and the
chaining of their effects as they go
down so when you're thinking about an
array flatmap makes sense but when
you're thinking about some of these
other types
it just doesn't convey like what's
actually going on with these so if I
were to chain this I now get everything
back so that null record where the
learner was null is now in nothing and
everything that does not have an a or
that has a name that matches our
criteria is there so we took care of the
actual validating super-simple now
there's a problem we have these two
separate streams we have these two
things that are going on so remember
earlier when I was talking about the
independence of a product type we're now
going to kind of exploit that so we can
think about each one of these values
after the functions been ran on them
living inside of a pair so inside that
pair we'll have the results of each so
in Crocs we have a function called valid
record we have a function called fan out
and what fan out does is it's going to
take in two functions and it's going to
take in one value and what it's going to
do is run that run that one value over
the let the first function and deposit
that inside the left side and it's going
to take that same value and run it on
the right function or the second
function and deposit that on the right
side so we'll now have the results of
both of these in one pair existing
independently all based off of one value
so that's where we get
independence from so for this all we
have to do is take our validate learner
and we need to take our validate record
but notice your silly validate or our
valid score did I call it passing I
called it pass passes with right yeah so
and then here we just applied that to 70
so we want anything that passes with 70
and we could bring that score in and
push it down and things like that but
there's no reason to do all that here we
can always go back and modify that when
we want to so now we'll just take a
little look-see at what we have here
so if I have valid record a validate or
valid record and I pass in X no errors
no errors all right so you'll see here
we have give that another save you'll
see we have a pair and on the left side
sorry we have a function which is wrong
here we need to do a valid learner to
apply that okay so now you'll notice on
the left side we have everything having
to do with the user and on the other
side we have everything having to do
with the learner and on the right side
we have everything that has to do with
the score bringing that entire object
back and some of these are just and some
of these are nothing but remember we
only care if it passes both things so we
really only care where a just appears in
both places and I think there's just two
of these three of these now two of Tomas
and he has a score of 72 oh yeah there's
three of these there's three of them
that have a just in both
Isis so just like before when we were do
what we need to do now is merge these
back together and with these algebraic
data types there's another thing that we
can do with them and that is we call it
the applicant or the apply we can take
and merge these two types together these
two same instances of the type and not
only use their values but apply their
effects so what that means is if there's
a nothing on one and a just on the other
it's going to be a nothing all the way
down if there's nothing on the right and
adjust in the left that's going to be in
nothing but if they're both just then
I'll get the just back and the result of
that function will be wrapped in a just
so this way we can take these two
separate streams of effects and combine
them into one effect so essentially
we've branched and now we have to merge
so there is a function inside of Crocs
called merge that takes a pair or takes
a binary function then takes a pair and
then applies those values to the binary
function the left gets applied to the
first argument and the right gets
applied to the second so that and that
will take two values and put them into
one so we're going to use what is this
validate record and that's going to be a
composition of the other thing we want
to do is valid record validate record
and here we want to do merge now to get
the effects to actually apply we're
going to use another function called
lift a two and the a stands for
applicative but what that means is we're
going to take a function and then we're
going to lift it inside of the maybe and
then apply the values inside the maybe
to it that's why it's called lift we're
going to lift it into the maybe apply
these values and give another maybe back
now we already have the transformation
that happened and that happened on the
left side
so because all we really want here is
just the username or the learner name
right so because that's on the left side
we really don't care about the right
side at all like who cares we only had
that in there just so we could validate
it so we have what are called
Combinator's or combiners depending I've
heard it both ways if you ever watch
Psych no anyone heard it both ways
alright so we have these combined ITER's
or Combinator's that allow you to kind
of change how and compose is one of them
it basically takes functions and allows
you to change how you call those
functions so what we're going to do is
use one of those called constant now if
you're familiar with Ram de or things
like that that is always and what
constant or always does is it's going to
take one argument then it's going to
ignore your second argument and it's
always going to return that first
argument again so that way we get a
function that always returns the first
thing you pass to it which is exactly
what we need because we don't care about
the second argument we care about the
first argument so we're going to lift a
two on digital constant and if we come
here and do validate record mm-hmm thank
you
[Music]
okay why did that not work validate
record takes the compose oh no it worked
so now you'll see that too everywhere
that we had it we have nothing but these
just sand you know just Joan and then
anything that didn't pass both criteria
have now become nothing but if we go
back and look at our requirements they
said nothing about including maybes in
it they want the actual names their
problem is were in an array but I got a
secret for you an array believe it or
not is actually also a some type so it's
a some type just like the other ones
except the left side of it is an empty
array and the right side of it is an
array that has things in it kind of maps
very nicely some might say naturally to
what the maybe is on the left side it
has nothing on the right side it has a
value so we should be able to take that
natural feel or that natural
relationship there and transform an
array or a maybe into an array so bob is
not valid because he has three yep you
know Bob's not valid don't tell him that
we don't want to fix the glitch if you
know what I mean I'm making too many
movie references you guys haven't seen
it yeah okay all right I'll cool it on
those I found the hard way in doing
videos especially when they get and
internationalised don't make word puns
word puns don't translate to people that
don't speak your language it's something
you just learned after complaint after
complaint after complaint yeah exactly
that's horrible alright so now we have
this I'm curious let's see if it
huh it did okay
so by the way if you notice or have
noticed we actually I don't know if
people mentioned it a lot but in the
newest versions of node and chrome you
have flat map on array so now you can do
cool little Haskell things without
having to use the library like rocks you
can just call flat map they added that
without I mean they told people but no
one really thought that was really cool
and what on and on about it at least in
my channels anyway but we're not we're
not going to do that what we will do
though because it doesn't really match
the laws of course like they just can't
seem to get it right so that should have
failed on me because I didn't return an
array I would have to return an array
for that to be valid but JavaScript they
don't do it right so mathematically
since my function is correct
mathematically we'll go with that one
but really all we need to do to make
this program and one of the things
you'll notice we started at the lowest
level and we've now worked our way up
everything that's been validated every
little requirement that was there we
worked on each requirement individually
and then we moved up a level and then up
a level and up a level until we got to
the hole so instead of going hold down
or top down we went bottom up and
implemented it that way
so we will do program and now our new
program is just going chain and remember
that natural transformation I was
talking about we can then do maybe or
maybe two array and maybe two arrays
kind of an odd little sucker so its
first argument will either take a
function that returns the type that
you're going from or it'll take an
instance of the type you're going from
so that way you can either put in what's
called the closley arrow like the
you could put in a function that returns
that or you can go ahead and just give
an instant and immediately flatten it if
you need to here we're going to use the
function portion of it and all we need
to do program is put in validate record
and here all we have to do is do a
program and put in our data and it's
done the only two people we have is Joan
and Thomas I thought that was three but
why is there not three because Joey Joey
failed
Joey failed big time yeah so there's I
mean that's it that's how to implement
this so there are some drawbacks there's
a lot of pros to it but there are some
drawbacks and things like that that you
kind of have to consider when doing this
so why would even want to do this right
so there's some pros number one we can
focus just on the logic and make sure
that we have everything put together
based on the requirements that we have
and not some overreaching requirement it
makes it easier to extend well yeah this
goes along with that so now we can
implement each of these requirements in
isolation
I started at that one but I didn't have
to start there I could have started at
any requirement and worked on that
individual requirement and then later
put it all together so it lets you do
stuff in isolation also in doing this
it's easier to write specs for imagine
writing first specs you would have all
these ridiculous specs for the just so
simple like for each ones to account for
every case that comes in whereas here I
can pick it I can make a spec to the REC
I can make a spec to the rec and I like
that I'm gonna sticker that and it just
makes it easier to test think at least
for doing unit tests and then your
integration tests or basically did your
composition work right
for that that part of it but you can
compose small and easy to reason about
units of code now what I mean by easy to
reason about is I'm only looking at one
small thing all these compositions if
you look at them they don't go beyond
three so it's real easy to say what does
this do also each one of these
compositions have a name so once you get
used to like once you get used to what
these functions do you can go ahead and
just if you're digging in and trying to
find a bug just by looking at the names
of the functions you should be able to
figure out where that bug is happening
and what's going on and you really only
need to make small my new changes like
when you're doing feature extension and
stuff most of the time there are times
where yeah it's not fun but hey yeah
well I wish so again it's real easy to
create new programs like now that we
have all these little requirements a lot
of times and you'll notice that
requirements that come from the business
they're the same a lot of them are the
same but just in a different context so
this allows you to use these small
composable units to reuse the same
requirements just in different areas
because they were built at the atomic
level and also we only went over two
simple aspects of two very simple
structures there are a lot of these out
there well not a lot there's a few
there's some between abstract algebra
and category theory there's some pretty
cool stuff in there but a lot of this
talks about the underlying driving bits
of programming so it's the abstract of
like what makes programming programming
and why is this true so as you learn if
you decide to take this route you'll
start to notice these product types
everywhere you'll notice some types and
things like that even though they may
not be explicitly called out you'll
start to see that and if you know their
properties even not doing this
declarative style you'll still know the
guarantees that you get from you
that type or that structure and there's
many lives out there there's Ram de
there's Crocs there's folk tale there's
flu Chur there's a lot of libraries out
there that can aid you in doing this
sanctuary there are some cons like with
anything there's a drawback
so all these compositions you make you
have to maintain them it's very
important that this type goes to this
type this type goes to that type most of
the time it's not a problem because a
lot of this stuff you can take any type
a and you know return a may be like with
most of that maybe code it's not that
hard but there's some times where some
of your type signatures are going to get
out of hand and they need to be
maintained it's just something to be
aware of like with any code it requires
some gazing into the future because you
don't want to go in and like choose a
pattern like an API for what you're
doing you want to be careful about how
you choose it because it might be hard
to change later on but the good news is
if you you're not really gazing into the
future you're looking at like alright
what are the points of variability on
this and that's where like your context
and your data comes into play and it's
just a matter of which context goes
first basically so it's not really
gazing into the future of your project
but trying to recognize how things could
change over time there is a lot of
indirection you notice instead of one
function we blew up into eight functions
so a lot of it while you're digging
through code you have to get used to
that indirection and a lot of like good
naming will keep a lot of that jumping
just like Ruby code if you name things
well you don't have to comment and you
don't really have to jump because the
function since it's only doing one or
two things it's very easy to come up
with a name of what that function is
doing but you do have to get used to
that indirection yeah it's just one of
the costs of it all so if you work on it
on a team your whole team has to buy
into this you can't it's like me going
alright guys we're doing 6502 assembly
no one's going to go for that and but
everybody if we decide that go that way
they have to do the 62 or 6502 assembly
and there is a slight learning curve
first unlike object-oriented programming
where it could take a lifetime to master
there's really only a few concepts a lot
of the concepts are repeated and just at
a different level so there is a slight
learning curve at first but you overcome
that pretty quickly but and then you'll
learn how to not be able to explain the
Monad by the way we used functors and
monads and applic it is like all those
things that you might have heard on
blogs we just used all of them right now
I didn't call him out because I didn't
want to scare anyone but everything we
were doing was all monads all the time
like that that's what they are there's
nothing scary about them all right so we
kind of went over sorry about that I'm
not going to bring this keyboard next
time man we're done
[Applause]